Good morning everybody.
This is the last lecture in Roman architecture and I think it's appropriate that
I delivered this last lecture,
which I call Rome of Constantine and new Rome on Rome's birthday.
Indeed,
this is Rome's birthday today,
April 21st,
2009 Rome was born as you'll recall on the 21st of April in 753 BC,
which means that Rome is 2,762 years old today and since birthdays are often
celebrated with cake and ice cream.
I should make good today on the promise that I made to you at the very beginning
of the semester,
which is that sometime in the course of the semester I would recommend for ice
cream places to you for Gelato Rias in Rome to you and I've only recommended to,
I recommended Tracy [inaudible] and our [inaudible] rep and I recommended the
della Paloma that is located near the Pantheon so I haven't there two more to go
and it seemed on Rome's birthday this was the perfect thing to to begin the
lecture with.
And that is to round the circle a and make you aware of the two other best ice
cream places in Rome.
And I show you here on the left hand side of the screen,
uh,
Joe Ladies and on the right hand side of the scene,
son crispy,
no,
and note the birthday balloons.
And that I'm enjoying myself very much on Rome's birthday,
uh,
today.
Uh,
but just so that you know where these are,
you know,
Rome so well by now that I think I can give you directions that are going to
make sense to you.
So you have,
you are in the core of ancient Rome.
You've just been to visit the Coliseum and the Roman forum.
Maybe you've been up on the Capitoline hill,
you're exploring the Victor Emmanuel monument.
And so with your back to the Victor Emmanuel monument,
look straight ahead and you see the Corso,
the so called Corso the street of the race course race courses,
or the race course,
uh,
where the pope's,
by the way used to race their horses.
Uh,
you stand with your facing the course.
So you walk down the course.
So you're on your way in this regard toward the Piatsa Dysphonia,
the Spanish steps.
But before you get to the Spanish steps,
you're going to notice a one the only,
uh,
the only a department store in Rome,
Rena Shane Day.
That's why it's a good landmark.
Rena,
shame day on the right,
you take a left and you're going to see the column of Marcus and release,
which is a column we didn't look at this semester.
But as based on the column of Trajan,
you take a look at the column of Marcus and really as you continue into the next
Piatsa,
which is the Piatsa Montagey Tortilla with a great obelisk and the center and a
government building and a couple of hotels,
you stay on the right and you go down that next small street and you hit Joe
Levy,
which in my opinion,
is the single best ice cream place in Rome.
So if you're in Rome and not to be missed,
it has the best fruit flavors in the city of Rome.
In fact,
anywhere in Italy,
uh,
that I know of.
And the second one that I mentioned to you,
his son Crespino son Crespino,
is near the Trevi Fountain in Rome.
So you're gonna go to the Trevi fountain in any case.
Uh,
and all you need to do when you're facing the Trevi fountain is to go,
go about two blocks away from the Trevi fountain and you will hit some crispy.
No,
it has a smaller selection of flavors,
but everything is very,
very good there.
In fact,
they've been such a success that they have expanded and opened another one near
the Pantheon.
Uh,
so again,
back to the pantheon down that small street,
I already gave you the directions to Della Palma.
You go beyond della Paul and me.
You take a left and you'll hit the second son.
Crespino so,
uh,
very important to,
to share this with you again before the term is up and in honor of Rome's
birthday.
Also of course when you're at Sun Crespino,
don't forget the Trevi Fountain and you probably all know the tradition that
when you go and visit the Trevi Fountain,
which is always very crowded,
this is actually a small crowd compared to what's usually there after you've
looked at it and enjoyed it for its own sake.
And for architecture obviously have a much later period.
But I think one you can see is very closely based on a lot of things that we've
been looking at this semester.
After you've looked at it,
and people usually do this right before they leave Rome,
you go up to the fountain,
bring a coin can be,
it can be an,
you know,
an American coin or Italian coin or any coin for that matter.
You stand in front of the Trevi Fountain with your back to the Trevi fountain.
You take a coin,
you throw it over your shoulder,
that to make sure it gets,
it goes into the water and not on the side,
but throw it into the water.
And that will ensure that you will get to return to Rome someday.
So don't forget to do that as well.
We spoke on the,
in the last lecture,
uh,
about the tetrarchy about Diocletian and his formation of the tetrarchy,
and his attempt to bring stability back to Rome and to the empire and how
successful he was.
Indeed.
A,
we also talked about the fact that Diocletian and the other tetrarchy we're
responsible for some important building projects.
In fact,
building,
bringing architecture back to Rome,
uh,
in a way that had it had been missing in the third century.
Ady and I mentioned in particular that Diocletian was interested both in public
and in private architecture.
And I remind you of an example of public architecture that we looked at last
time on the top left.
Uh,
the so called five column monument or descendible monument or Tetrarch,
if monument that Diocletian erected in the Roman forum to honor himself,
uh,
and honor his formation of the tetrarchy and his relationship to Jupiter.
You'll remember the five columns for a,
with the tech parks imaged on the top and the front,
the one of Jupiter behind that this was located behind the roster or the
speakers platform.
In the Roman forum.
We also talked about the fact that Diocletian was interested again in private
architecture,
that he built a palace for himself,
a place that he hoped to retire to in on the Dalmatian coast where he was born
at a place called split.
And I remind you of it here,
a restored view showing you what it looked like.
That it was essentially a fortified camp,
uh,
designed like a Roman cost from,
with walls and towers and a very distinctive octagonal Maza Liam that was
located across from the temple of Jupiter.
So again,
is connected,
connecting himself to Jupiter,
honoring Jupiter as the honors himself.
And I also showed you an example of the portraiture of the tetrarchy.
We talked about the all for one and one for all philosophy,
how they stuck together not only in life,
but in their portraits and they depicted themselves or they had themselves
depicted as this foursome in large part.
Again to underscore the fact that all four of them were coequal emperors,
uh,
that all four of them are almost coequal them for will remember that there were
all gousty and Caesars of some had the slight upper hand,
but for the most part,
they work together now represented as a whole.
Uh,
and they're represented in very similar way to one another.
And we talked about the use of geometric forms,
the abstraction,
the solidity of these portraits that I suggested mirrors this new stability that
Diocletian and the tetrarchy have brought,
uh,
to Rome and to the empire.
And we saw that those same qualities,
that interest in geometry and obstruction and solidity,
uh,
were characteristic also of Tetra archaic architecture.
And we're going to see some of those features,
uh,
continuing on in the buildings that we're going to be looking at today.
Diocletian uh,
a stepdown retired voluntarily on the 1st of May in 305.
And the,
uh,
Maximilian his co Augustus stepped down as well.
And the two Caesars were elevated to our gousty and two new Caesars were chosen.
But without the strong presence of Diocletian,
the tetrarchy fell apart and Rome and the empire where once again plunged into
civil war,
the two main claimants,
four imperial power that came out of this civil war where Max [inaudible],
Max Sanchez,
who was the son of Maximilian and Constantine Constantine,
who eventually became Constantine,
the Great Constantine who was the son of [inaudible] as Cloris and these two
men,
Constantine and Max inches ward with one another for imperial power.
And they went against one another in one of the most famous battles of all,
in fact,
the battle that is as well known,
if not even more well known than the battle of Actium.
And this is the battle of the mill vion bridge,
the battle of the mill vion bridge,
which took place in 312 a d,
and it was at that epic making battle that Constantine was victorious over Max
inches,
that Constantine became sole emperor of Rome.
So a move away from the tetrarchy and the placement of power in the hands of one
man.
Once again,
Constantine becomes sole emperor of Rome and it was at that same battle,
the battle of the Milby and bridge,
and one of the reasons that it's such an important battle in historical terms is
the fact that it was at that battle of the mill vion bridge that Constantine was
said to have seen the vision of the cross,
the vision of the process that helped him to be victorious,
the vision of the cross,
that that eventually led him to convert to Christianity,
which he did on his back and his deathbed.
He was baptized a Christian on his deathbed.
One of the most interesting things that we'll talk about today and about the
architecture under Constantine,
the great is that we will see because he w he began as a pagan emperor and ended
his life as a Christian emperor.
He has in a sense,
one foot in the pagan past and the other foot in the Christian future and we're
going to see that reflected in the architecture that he commissioned.
As we look at that today,
a few coins of Constantine,
which I think will help set the stage for this one foot in the past and one foot
in the future.
That is going to be the light motif of today's lecture.
I show you on the lefthand side of the screen,
a coin of Constantine.
When he first began his rise to power,
it was probably,
uh,
struck in around 306 a d.
And it's an interesting coin because if you remember,
I didn't bring it back to show you,
but if you remember the coin of Diocletian that I showed you,
you'll recall that he was represented in a very similar fashion.
It's the sort of bearded blockhead style,
as I call it,
for the tetrarchy,
a very cubic image,
a short military hairstyle,
closely cropped a and a short beard that adheres very closely to the shape of
the face,
uh,
and the,
the face in mast itself with cubic geometric forms.
So we see Constantine in his very early portrait trying to look like a trek
tetrarch trying to look like his father and status core is trying to look like
Diocletian trying to fit in before he figures out the way that's going to enable
him.
In fact to become emperor for sole emperor of Rome after he defeats Maxentius at
the battle of the Milby and bridge,
we see the greatest transformation in the history of Roman portraiture and the
history of self imaging by emperors,
by people in power.
And that is this transformation that I can show you from this early coin of
three six to a coin.
The dates after the battle of the mill and bridge and that also represents
Constantine and what you see has happened to your has cons is Constantine has
shaved off his beard,
he has lost about 20 years of age and he is shown with an entirely different
hairstyle,
not the,
not the short military hairstyle that he wore,
a because he wanted to likened himself to his father and to Diocletian,
but an entirely new hairstyle.
But one for any of you who know your Roman portraiture or remember the portraits
that I showed you,
fleetingly of Augustus and the Julio Claudine's,
he is wearing a cap of hair that is very similar to a fuller cap of hair with a
comma shape blocks over his bar had growing long on the nape of his neck that is
characteristic of Augustus and also of Trajan.
He's in fact a neo Augustus in this image with a neo Trey Janick hairstyle.
Why?
Because he is at sole emperor.
He has made the decision that he wants to now ally himself not with the Tetra
Arcs,
which are of the past at this point,
but rather with the,
with the great emperors of the past with Augustus,
with Trajan.
And as we'll see also with Hadrian and with Marcus a released.
And we can see that very important break here and we'll see it also in
architecture.
Uh,
another coin down here representing a Constantine,
uh,
with a,
with a bunch of Pagan Regalia.
We see him as so many of the emperors earlier,
emperors of Rome depicted along with a patron.
God,
in this case,
the God,
Helios,
the god of the Sun.
Uh,
and you can see Constantine in the foreground,
Helios in the background,
a Helios represented with the raid crown.
And that's why we know it's him silhouetted right behind the emperor.
The emperor is shown,
is warlike with military costume,
his spear,
and then a shield over here.
And if we look closely at the shield,
will see the depiction of someone in a chariot,
uh,
led by four horses coming.
It's represented frontally.
It's the solar cherry at the solar chariot of Helios.
So a coin that is very much in the usual pagan tradition where we see
Constantine associating himself with,
uh,
with,
with the pagan past,
uh,
and uh,
and with a pagan God in this case,
Helios.
This coin,
however,
that was also made after the battle of the Milby and bridge shows us a very
different Constantine.
It's an interesting frontal portrait,
which is rare on a Roman coins.
Uh,
he is still shown as the warrior.
He's in military costume.
He has,
he's holding the reins of his horse.
He was also depicted nicely in this portrait on this coin.
Uh,
if you look very closely at his shield,
you will actually see that it still is decorated with a pagan symbol with the
she wolf suckling Romulus and Remus.
But look up here,
the sector that he carries is not the usual septor or spear that we see in pagan
imagery,
but I a cross sector across sector and I don't know if you can see it from where
you sit.
He wears a,
a medallion on the top of his very elaborate help helmet with plumage and so on
a medallion that has the Chi Rho,
c h,
I o Dash r h o,
the Chi Rho,
which was the Christian monogram.
So we see him in this image,
not as the great pagan warrior,
but as the new Christian preset crusader.
So a very important change,
uh,
from paganism to Christianity.
Then as I mentioned already,
we will see also reflected in Constantine's architecture.
Constantine,
uh,
learned a lot though from the tech trucks.
And one of the things that he continued on,
uh,
was to build a great public architecture,
public architecture for the benefit of the Roman populace at large.
He follows the lead of Diocletian in this regard and adds another very large
imperial bath to Rome.
And I show you a plan of that imperial bath here at bears,
his name,
the bads of Constantine and dates to 320 and it is located in Rome.
Uh,
it is located on the queer knowl hill,
the queer and Phil Hill.
And that should ring a bell for all of you because you'll remember it was Trajan
Trajan.
And remember Constantine is imaging himself as a neo Augustus with a neo Trey
Janick hairstyle Trajan who built,
who had the,
a much a good part of the queer and it'll help cut back to make way for his
forum and then placed his markets on part of what remained of the queer and mill
hill.
So the queer and all hell was,
was associated in everybody's mind,
uh,
with Trajan.
Constantine wanted to associate himself with Trajan.
So when he decides where to place is a new bath structure,
he chooses the queer and all hell.
This is not coincidentally,
it was very deliberative on his part.
He builds it in a manner that is completely consistent with imperial,
a bath architecture in Rome,
the imperial bath type of architecture in Rome that we've already studied from
the time of Titus up through the time of Diocletian,
the,
uh,
the bags on the queer and hill are no longer preserved,
but we fortunately have some drawings that were made,
uh,
by the famous architect Andrea Palladio,
p a,
l l a d I o undrip Lado who,
uh,
who drew it when it was in better shape and has,
and his drawings of the bads of Constantine allow us to see exactly what these
bats were like in their hay day.
Uh,
and we can see,
although plot it Palladio's drawing concentrates on the bathing block.
Uh,
you can see that he also includes down here and it's probably that this is all
that remained of this particular part of the bath and Palladio's time.
You can see he includes down here the Great Hemi cycle that we've seen in so
many of these bands that are part of that precinct that surrounds the bath,
the bath block.
So this suggests to us,
and I think very convincingly,
ah,
that this bath is bathing block was also placed in one of these very large
precincts that had all the seminar and lecture rooms and libraries around the
perimeter of it and that this was lined with seats and probably use too for
people to watch athletic contests or perhaps even a plays of other kinds.
The bathing block,
again,
we can see conforms extremely well to the other bats that we've looked at to the
baths of Caracalla and Diocletian.
For example,
with a natap deo rectangular in shape with a frigate Doriam that is also
rectangular and has three a triple groin vault.
As you can see designated in Palladio's drawing and down here.
This is a reinterpretation by the way of Palladio's drawing from Ward Perkins.
This plan that you see on the screen now,
a tip Darian over here,
that's something somewhat more unusual in shape.
Then then we,
then we tend to see where we have a series of Lobes,
four lobes in fact that have been,
that have expanded the space almost.
Well,
it's,
it's sort of a circle trying to become an oval,
I suppose.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you can see,
the way in which they have expanded and we call that kind of a space quadro low
bait quadrilles debate.
Uh,
and we see that here.
And then we also see this is most interesting how the call Darian is treated
because as you've seen in the baths that we've looked at,
the imperial bats that we've looked at,
if there's any room that's different in each of these,
it's the caldarium.
You'll recall that Diocletian had moved to a rectangular called Darian with
radiating alcoves but Constantine and his architects move back to the circular
called rem that we saw in the baths of Caracalla uses the same sort of scheme
here with three radiating alcoves,
all of those screened from the outer space with columns a and the rest of the
structure around these,
these main rooms of the bathing block that are related to one another axial
axially.
We see the other rooms symmetrically disposed.
One other important point to make about the caldarium is that we see that it to
corresponds to a development that we've already begun to see in some of the
other buildings that we looked at,
especially in the last lecture.
And that is this move away from the Oculus for round domed buildings.
This round,
this call arm does not have an Oculus as so many call Daria did in the past
thing back to the,
uh,
well or so many bathing rooms did think back to the frigging Daria and pom pay,
for example,
with their Oculus,
the Oculus is no longer used here.
And instead we see windows in the base of the Dome that are very similar to the
windows that we saw in a couple of tetrarch buildings.
We're going to see it elsewhere today and I'll reiterate that point then.
Constantine,
like so many Roman emperors before him,
uh,
did complete buildings that had been begun by his predecessors.
Uh,
and he did this,
uh,
for,
some of the tech,
including father,
not surprisingly,
can stand just Cloris.
We know that can stand just Cloris had chosen as his capital a as the city of
trickier the city of [inaudible] in,
uh,
what was goal but was,
but,
but now is Germany.
Uh,
and I show you the location of tree or this is a map showing the locations of,
as we've discussed so many times this term of many of the,
of all of the places that we've looked at in the western empire.
Uh,
and you can see the French cities that we looked at,
just less time and goal and then up there a trader in what is now Germany
located near the modern city of Cologne.
Uh,
this was the chosen capital for can stand just Cloris even before Constancia is
Cloris began to build a palace for himself at Tria as the other tech drugs had
done elsewhere in the Roman provinces.
Uh,
there was quite a bit of building activity going on with regard to one project
in trior in the third century.
And not surprisingly,
that too was a defensive wall that part of the empire was being attacked on a
regular basis by a Germanic tribes.
By the Franks and by the all Amani,
uh,
we're coming in wrecking havoc in that part of the world.
Uh,
and a decision was taken and not surprisingly in 275 and 276 cause you'll
remember that's exactly when the really enrolls were dedicated in Rome,
275 a to build a major wall in this part of the empire as well.
And we have some part of that wall still preserved,
especially a gate in that wall called the Porta Negro,
which I show you here on the right hand side of the screen in the port in Negro,
which although the walls were begun in the two seventies,
so the walls date primarily in the third century,
this particular gate was not added to the walls until the early fourth century.
D during the time of Constancia is Cloris.
Uh,
and Constantine completes,
uh,
this,
this gateway in the,
those bads.
If we compare the gate at the port a Negro and trior to the gate that we looked
at from the really end walls is so called Puerto Apia that does date to around
275 and you see it again in this restored view from Ward Perkins on the left
hand side of the screen,
you will see the close resemblance of the port a Negro to the port,
the majority in Rome.
By that I mean both of them have to RQ to RQ weighted entrance ways.
Both of them have round towers.
As you can see here.
Uh,
both of them have a RQ weighted RQ,
weighted windows,
uh,
or blind windows.
As you can see in the case of the port a Negro,
they have columns between them,
which is not the case in the poor to Apia.
The main difference between the two,
between these two content between these two is that the Porta Apia in Rome,
you'll recall was out of concrete faced with brick,
uh,
the most contemporary building material.
Whereas you can clearly see by looking at the port a Negro that the port in
Negro is made out of stone,
out of cut stone construction,
extremely old fashioned at this particular time.
Uh,
but I think it is very likely that they wanted by choosing this for this
particular part of the world.
And it is,
uh,
it is this cut stone construction is local stone.
By choosing this,
they wanted to reassert a,
a relationship between the early fourth century ID and earlier Rome and
especially earlier Roman imperial power.
The very symbols of Roman power buildings like the theater of Marcel is,
and especially the Colosseum in Rome,
we've talked about that as the icon of Rome.
It's ability to impress and to all.
And I think they wanted to take advantage of that kind of awe inspiring,
uh,
rhetoric,
you know,
a visual rhetoric that such a choice could make.
And I think it's an example of the fact,
you know,
just as Constantine reaches back to emperors like Trajan to Augustus to
associate himself with in his portraiture.
I think that,
uh,
that there was a,
they had reason to look back to some of the great buildings of the Roman past,
uh,
two and to use that,
that kind of visual imagery to reassert that Rome,
despite the fact that they were being attacked by barbarians,
all was well in Rome.
Paul continued to be well in the Capitol as well as on the frontiers.
And this kind of image I think worked,
uh,
in that regard.
Well,
one hopes that that will,
they thought it would work at any rate in that regard,
even into the early fourth century.
A D is another view at the same view of the port a Negro.
And I compare it also to a detail from the porter majority in Rome,
which you'll recall was built by Claudius.
There is an interesting resemblance between the two and many scholars have
called attention to that because the stone of the port of Negro is not as
smoothed over as the stone of the Colosseum or the theater of Marcellus.
It's left in a much more rough state,
a rough state that reminds one of the rustic dicated masonry of Claudius has
poured a majority.
But remember that in the case of the port,
the majority,
there was a deliberate,
uh,
the deliberate disjunction between the rustication masonry and the finished
masonry,
the finished capitals,
and also the finished,
uh,
pediments above.
And we talked about the fact that we believe that that has a lot to do with a
particular personality and antiquarian interest.
And Claudius who liked the intellectual exercise and idea of playing off one
against the other.
We don't see that same combination here.
We don't see the rough and the,
and the finished,
uh,
in the case of the port,
the port of Negro and treer.
And it has been suggested and I think correctly,
so that the reason that the,
and need where looks the way it does is not the deliberate,
the way the port of majority is,
but rather because it really was unfinished.
It would,
the blocks were never fully smoothed over,
but it,
but it makes it very attractive appearance even still today,
despite that,
Constantine,
uh,
so Constantine completed this gateway,
but he also completed the palace that had been begun by his father can stand,
is Flores had begun a palace and tree or the palace had a very large and
impressive bath building as a piece of it.
Uh,
and it also had this building that is usually referred to today as the
[inaudible] Palatino or the basilica,
the Allah Palatine or the basilica.
We're not exactly sure how it was used in the palace,
but possibly in the same way that the basilica was in the,
uh,
in the palace of Domitian Domitian on the Palatine hill as a place where he
could sit and try cases himself.
It may have been used in the same fashion here and I can show you it's extremely
WellPreserved at dates to 300 to 310 a d again,
part of the palace of Constancia is Cloris completed by Constantine.
We see a plan and a restored view from Ward Perkins now on the screen.
And if you look at the plan,
uh,
you will see that in the main,
it follows the Basilican plan that we've become so accustomed to a great open
rectangular space within apps on one end and with all attention drawn toward
that apps.
Uh,
so in that sense,
again,
one foot in the pagan past,
it looks back to basilicas of an earlier date,
be they the one in dimensions palace or,
uh,
or,
or the forum of Trajan in Rome.
But there are some differences here.
Uh,
one of them is the fact that you can see that there are no columns inside the
cellar.
That's interesting.
And it is in keeping with the tetrarchy aesthetic that we've already described
for the Korea,
for example,
with that,
that that a box like a box like open space inside a without any columnar
decoration at all,
no columns in here,
stark geometric abstract and the tetrarch manner.
But they have placed columns on the outside of the basilica in a,
in,
uh,
in a,
in a kind of courtyard on either side,
uh,
columns,
that you can see here,
which is a very interesting and unusual,
uh,
and in fact unique,
approach.
You can also see there's a transverse Carter,
uh,
over here and that are trends verse entrance,
vestibule,
transverse vestibule,
entrance vestibule,
which is unusual in which we don't see in Roman and typical Roman basilican
architecture.
We call that a Narthex and a r,
t h,
e x.
And this edition of the Narthex here,
this,
this transverse a vestibule is interesting because it is going to become the
basis for most church architecture,
both from the Tom Basilican church architecture in the time of Constantine
because Constantine does found all,
it does build old Saint Peter's and other churches in Rome,
uh,
and others follow suit.
So this,
those are the,
so getting one foot in the pagan past one in the Christian future on the left
hand side of the screen,
the restored view of the exterior,
uh,
shows not only those low lying,
columnar,
uh,
courtyards,
but also that there were railings on two stories.
Uh,
it does show you as well.
And the building is made out of solid brick.
Uh,
it does show you as well the rounded windows,
the arched windows,
which we have seen,
uh,
the round top windows which we have seen have become customary for tetrarchy
architecture as well as a very interesting use of projecting elements that are
very simple.
They look almost like pilasters,
but they're not pilasters there a simplified abstract version of pilasters.
So this,
this paring down of the elements that is so consistent with the tetrarchy ethos.
Here's a view of the outlet Palatino as it looks today.
Uh,
again,
it is extremely well preserved as you can see,
uh,
but it does no longer has its outer courtyard and it no longer has its railings.
Uh,
but the rest is there.
You can see these wonderful round headed windows and how large they are.
We've talked about the ability of architects to dematerialize the wall at this
point in time and the way in which they have opened it up with very large
windows.
And you can see what I was describing just before these molded elements that
project out into our space.
They kind of look like they're made to conjure up pilasters but they don't have
any capitals and they don't have any basis there in my mind,
a kind of abstract version,
uh,
of what,
of a pilaster and they're very effective I think.
Uh,
in terms of the aesthetic appeal of this particular building
while the basilica at the palace at Tria,
the palace of Constantia is Cloris at trickier is so clearly based on earlier
Roman basilican architecture.
It looks to the future.
And we,
if we look around Rome,
uh,
in,
in the years following the construction of buildings like the Owlet Palatino,
we see lots of early churches.
I show you the Church of Santa Sabina,
Sab Ina Santa Sabina in Rome,
which dates to 425.
And so the fifth century a d and I think you can see how similar it is,
uh,
to the,
to the owl Palatino,
the basilican form,
the apse at the end,
the very large,
uh,
rounded round top windows that we see in the basilica at Tria,
the interior of the,
uh,
Al Apella.
Tina is also very well preserved.
You see a view of it here.
It has been transformed not surprisingly into a church in later times.
It's a perfect space for that.
Uh,
and I think it's well worth comparing it to the interior of the Korea that we
looked at last time.
Because again,
it shows a,
a vision of the tetrarchy.
A vision of that is consistent from Rome to the provinces.
This whole idea of pairing things down to their basics of creating a box like
shape,
no columnar architecture whatsoever.
A very sparse,
the decorated rectangular space with a flat ceiling and with round headed
windows.
We see the same concept here.
Here they placed the round headed windows on two stories,
which is open the building up even more and create an allowed light to flow into
it.
No columnar decoration whatsoever.
The scheme of two rows of round headed windows in the niche as well.
Also opening it up,
dematerializing it,
allowing light to stream into the building in what is a very spiritual way and
again,
not at all surprising that it would be transformed in later times into a church.
Once again,
one foot in the pagan past one in the Christian future.
I show you a restored view.
We've looked at it before of the Basilica Olympia in Rome,
part of the forum of Trajan.
It's that kind of thing,
that kind of Basilican plan that lies beyond behind the design of the basilica
at,
uh,
at the palace of Constancia is Cloris and tree or,
but it also looks forward to others.
I show you here the Interior Santa Sabina.
This might not have been the best to choose because you can see the columns have
been reintroduced in the interior of Santa Sabina.
But if you think those columns away and just look at the way in which the apps
is designed with the rounded windows,
the same rounded windows in the upper story up here,
I think that you can see how much it owes a to buildings like the outlaw
Palatino
a domed roof,
excuse me,
round the round dome building type.
Just like the Basilican type,
uh,
was to be very important in the constant Tinian period.
Uh,
and also in later times.
and I show you,
I remind you of some of the important domed rooms that we've looked at in the
course of this semester at the frigate Doriam at the stobby and Baz upon pay at
the temple of Mercury from the spa at via the so called Temple of Mercury,
the uh,
the octagonal room of Nero's Domus area and the Dome of the Pantheon here on the
far right there is no more important form in Roman architecture.
Then the Dome Groom,
very characteristic of the Romans,
uh,
and uh,
a,
a special gift that they passed on a to posterity as you well know.
And this,
this type of building began to be explored,
continued to be explored in the constant Tinian period.
I could show you several examples,
but I've chosen,
uh,
to show you just one of those.
And it's the one that you now see on the screen and plan a plan from Ward
Perkins.
This is the so called Temple of Minerva Medica in Rome,
a,
it's not a temple at all,
at dates to the early fourth century,
a d it's not a temple,
but what it was was a pavilion in the garden.
We know that an emperor of the third century,
a d,
uh,
by the name of Galley Anus,
g a,
l,
I,
e,
n,
u s godliness,
uh,
was responsible for building some imperial gardens in the third century ID.
So this was another actually,
you know,
actually this was another project that did happen in the third century,
a day,
the building of some imperial gardens,
but the enjoyment of the emperors and of the imperial family.
Uh,
and it was in these gardens that were created in the third century that this
pavilion was added during the constant Tinian period in the early fourth
century,
a d and I show you a plan of that temple that so called Temple of Minerva
medical,
or this pavilion in the,
uh,
the so called Lice Sydney and lic.
I a n the Lice Sinthian gardens as a commissioned by a galley anus,
the lice Indian gardens.
And we see it here.
And it's very interesting because although it clearly I said it's a building
made out of concrete faced with brick and although it clearly is based on some
of the buildings that I just showed you,
the round of the typical round structure with Oculus,
the frigging Daria,
the spa,
the octagonal room,
and the Pantheon,
uh,
you can see that the architects of this period was still able to innovate,
and have gone further by creating,
not around building,
although at first it looks round or an octagonal building,
but a decagon all building a 10 sided building.
Uh,
and you can see 10,
you can see radiating apps is nine.
And then the entrance way over here.
Uh,
so 10 sided structure.
If you look very carefully at the plan,
you will notice though that the,
um,
that the upper most apps,
the one that is located directly across from the,
from the entrance way as a tiny bit larger than the others.
Uh,
so that gives the building a little bit,
even though it's around building a little bit of a,
of a longitudinal access,
which is very interesting,
is the incorporation of the longitudinal axis into a round structure.
Uh,
you can also see the way in which the radiating apps is the two on either side
left and right,
are screened by columns,
uh,
in a way that we've also become accustomed to.
Uh,
and I believe that those columns,
yes,
I'm pretty sure that those columns have a triple occupation up above.
Uh,
so that,
yeah,
you can see that in plan.
A typical triple occupation above,
uh,
that we've seen also is characteristic of,
of late Roman architecture.
Not only in the Po,
the private sphere is,
this is,
but also in the more public sphere.
Uh,
but going back to that longitudinal axis,
look also at the entrance vestibule.
This is another one of these north Texas.
This pross,
uh,
this transverse vestibule in this case with apps is on either end that is
characteristic of these,
uh,
these early fourth century Aidy,
Roman Pagan,
Roman buildings.
Uh,
but it's going to become a hallmark of Christian architecture,
not only basilican architecture that is churches in the form of Basilicas,
but a small,
uh,
religious structures,
in that are done,
that are circular in general plan.
So a very interesting plan in that regard and a very innovative plan,
uh,
in the early fourth century.
A d the building is still preserved.
I can show it to you.
Uh,
it dates of Sec,
I can show you the outside as well as some details of the inside of the building
as you see here.
Uh,
this,
it was made out of concrete,
faced with brick.
As I mentioned before,
we are looking at the interior up toward the dome.
Uh,
you can see something very interesting here,
which is the addition of ribbed,
uh,
of bricks to create ribs in the dome.
To give it a,
something of a sense of a segmented dome,
which is,
uh,
a building technique that we see sometimes in late Roman architecture.
Uh,
and you can also see,
although it looks like it has an Oculus,
that's just because the most of the roof is falling in.
It did not have an oculus.
Instead,
the lighting was provided through these round headed windows that we see very
large rounded windows at the base of the dome.
So again,
this move away in late antiquity from the Oculus to using these very large
rounded windows to light the interior of the building.
And this is a view of the so called Temple of nerve a Medica as it looks today
from the outside where you can see those same round headed buildings where you
can see those same sort of peers I've been,
are not so different from the ones that we saw at trior used rather than,
uh,
columns,
to decorate the structure.
A large round had a doorway down here.
You can see the scale.
This is a pretty big pavilion in a garden you can see at scale in relationship
to the cars that surround it.
So continued innovation in round architecture under Constantine,
the great,
uh,
and a building type that is going to have a long history,
in the medieval period and the Byzantine period and well beyond.
Uh,
I show you just one example of the impact that it had on later church
architecture.
This is the Church of San Vitali,
very famous church in Ravenna,
Italy.
That was,
uh,
that,
that honors,
uh,
Justinian and the famous Justinian and Theodora.
It was built in the sixth century a d.
And I think you can see by looking at a view of the exterior of plan and also a
view of the interior,
uh,
how important architectural experiments under the Romans were four buildings
like this,
the massing of the outside,
the geometry,
the interest in geometry is simple forms,
rounded windows.
So similar to the aesthetic that we saw on the Korea or in the basilica at Tria,
the plan above,
in this case,
uh,
an octagon,
a with a central area with radiating [inaudible] very similar to the sorts of
things that we see not just in the dome is salary,
but also in the temple of Minerva Medica.
And you can see the Narthex here just as we saw it in the temple of Minerva
Medica.
Uh,
and you can see in this view of the interior,
for example,
the triple r arches on top of the two columns.
All of these motifs taken over clearly from Roman architecture,
ancient Roman architecture and exploited in the medieval and Byzantine periods.
The single most important building that I am going to show you today,
uh,
is the one that I want to turn to now.
And this is the so called a basilica Nova or the basilica of Maxentius
Constantine.
I can't overemphasize the significance of this import of this incredible
building.
Uh,
it is a building that demonstrates to us that Constantine not only completed
commissions that had been begun by his father,
such as the palace at Trivia and the Porta Negro,
uh,
but also by other tech products.
And in this case by his rival Maxentius.
We know that this building was begun by Max inches,
which is why it is sometimes referred to as the basilica of Maxentius Dash
Constantine,
or more easily the Basilica Nova.
It was begun by Max inches in 306,
a d when Constantine was victorious over Max Sanchez at the battle of the mill
vion bridge.
He took it over and he completed it in his own name.
Uh,
the,
so hence the basilica of Maxentius Constantine or again,
more more easily the Basilica Nova.
Now let me show you where it is.
And by so doing,
it takes us back to a Google earth image that we've looked at time and again in
the course of the semester.
And I suppose in the last lecture it's very appropriate,
uh,
to go back to this particular aerial view,
to remind ourselves of everything we've covered in the center of Rome.
Just reminding you.
Of course,
the,
uh,
the circus maximus up here,
the Palatine hill,
originally with the Hudson Romulus and later with the palace of Demission,
uh,
the,
Capitol Line Hill over here as we designed by Michelangelo,
the wedding cake of Victor Emmanuel down here,
the via De 40 and periodically,
the imperial fora with the forum of Trajan.
Uh,
the area that was built up by Diocletian,
or one of the areas is the area over here,
uh,
which is where we see the Korea,
which was restored by Diocletian.
And also,
uh,
the five column monument are located on this side closest to the capital line
hill.
But Max sensuous was particularly interested in the area of the upper most area,
closer to the coliseum.
If you look right under the coliseum,
you can see the remains of the temple of Venus and Roma,
which we looked at earlier in the semester,
a temple of Venus and Roma.
That was the Greek import that Hadrian,
uh,
built,
and may have designed himself in Rome.
And it was that,
and I mentioned this at the time,
but you may have forgotten by now,
uh,
that at the time that,
that Max sent,
that the building burned down in a fire.
I remember that fire of two 83 that destroyed the,
the destroyed the Korea also destroyed part of the temple of Venus and Roma.
And it was rebuilt by Max,
sensuous,
by Max,
just by the tetrarch Max senses he built,
he rebuilt,
uh,
the,
the temple of Venus and Roma,
and do recall the niche that is well preserved,
uh,
with his rebuilding.
So it is not surprising to see him choosing the location right next store right
underneath the temple of Venus in Roma for his Basilica Nova in Rome when it
begins to be built and it's still is preserved on that site.
Today,
I show you a panorama,
uh,
that includes the Basilica Nova and you see it right here and you can see how
very large a building it is.
And they're only essentially three barrel vaults.
A small part of the building still preserved.
Uh,
but it gives you a sense of its scale when you compare it to some of the other
structures here.
Uh,
but you can see many that we've studied.
You can see the temple of and Tinnitus and Faustina.
You can see the arch of September is severity.
So you can see the Korea over here.
You can see the top,
you Laurium,
uh,
and the,
the Michelangelo,
uh,
Pr Palazzo that was built into that.
You can see the victor of manual monument over there.
And you can see on this side the arch of Titus,
the remains of the temple of Venus and Roma and so on.
So a very large building in the midst of an area that [inaudible] was
particularly interested in restoring.
Here's a view of the,
of the Basilica Nova as it looks today.
It's taken from the side,
the other side that with the,
with ones back to the Palatine Hill.
Uh,
and we can see here that it is a building made out of brick.
It is it out of concrete.
Excuse me.
Faced with brick,
we can see that the artists are better than ever at d materializing the
architects and designers better than ever at d materializing the wall.
They have used very large round headed windows here on two stories.
There's more window,
then there's wall.
That's how good they become at,
um,
at,
at manipulating the brick face,
concrete medium.
You see it in this wall over here as well.
And you see these three giant barrel vaults was soaring vaults are very
impressive work of architecture.
Let me show you a restored view,
uh,
of what the Basilica Nova would have looked like in its heyday.
And then let me say a little bit more about what happens when Constantine takes
over a construction of this particular building.
This restored view is very,
very interesting because it shows us that although this building was used
without question as a basilica,
that was its purpose of basilica.
Uh,
we will see that it is unlike we see here that is unlike any basilica that we
have seen in the course of the semester.
And I wonder as you look at this,
whether you can tell me if it's not,
it's not built like a customer per se.
It doesn't look like the Basilica Olympia in Roma doesn't look like the basilica
at trigger,
but it does look like what other kind of building
that we've seen time and again in the course of the semester.
Look at the vaulting,
look at the barrel vaults on either side,
look at the shape of the windows in the upper tier.
Look at the shape of the exterior of the building that is created by the choice
of vaulting.
What does this look like
if not a basilica?
Someone said a market.
Yes,
which,
yes,
who said bad structure?
That's the answer.
Which part of a of a typical Roman imperial bath does this look like?
The frigate Darian,
the frigging door and the freezer door and the great large rectangular space
with a triple groin vaulted roof with windows that are usually divided into
three parts on the upper most part.
And then buttressed by great barrel vaulted chambers.
This is a basilica that is built in the form of a frigging Doriam.
That's an awfully creative thing to do.
It shows us,
once again this interest in the interchangeability of form that you can take a
plan that was used for one kind of building and use it for another as they have
done so effectively here using a frigging Dari and plan for a basilica,
uh,
and capitalizing on that to make it work in this environment as well.
So some very creative minds,
I think at work in the time of Max inches.
And in the time of Constantine when the building was first designed for
[inaudible],
the idea was to have the entrance way on the uh,
eastern part of the building,
the eastern part of the building,
the part of the building that faces the Colosseum and uh,
to enter into it that way and to have the main apps be over here on,
uh,
the western end of the structure to give it a focus and the kind of focus one
would have seen in a typical Frigidaire ium as well as in a typical basilica.
Constantine comes in and takes it over and decides he wants to change the
orientation.
He wants the entrance way not to be closest to the Colosseum,
uh,
but rather to the Roman forum and to the sacred way.
And to the Veolia,
which is on the part on which this was built to the arch of Titus and he and he,
and he instructs his architects to change the orientation from an east west
orientation to a north south orientation and to place the entrance way on the
forum side on the south.
You also instructs them to put four columns here.
And these columns are made out of porphyry,
that purplish stone that's quarried in Egypt and that was used so extensively
for tetrarch it art to torque portraiture.
We see that here.
Then he's very tempted to change the orientation of the niche to instead of,
to put his portrait is Max [inaudible].
Max Engines intended to put his portrait in this his own partner that is of Max
inches in this apps.
Uh,
Constantine was probably attempted to put his own portrait in this apps over
here on the northern side so that it would be the first thing that you saw when
you came in.
But he resisted that temptation and decided to leave or to place a seated
portrait of himself in this niche.
Leave it where Maxentius intended it.
So you would have to enter the building and take an abrupt left,
uh,
to see that statue.
But we think we're not absolutely sure.
We think he may also have put another statute of themselves,
in this case,
a standing statue in this niche.
But as we'll see,
there are lots of niches in the wall of the,
of the northern end.
Uh,
and we think that there were statues of all of his lieutenants are the
lieutenants that had helped him when his great battle,
uh,
at the Milby and bridge that we're located in this niche.
So,
and he,
so he may have been shown,
they're surrounded by his most,
his most worthy and his most loyal lieutenants.
And then another statue of him seated in the niche over here.
So we see him again.
The most important thing is he shifts the orientation,
another restored view,
which perhaps in color,
which perhaps gives you a better sense of the majesty of this particular
building in its time.
Uh,
the entrance,
the constant Tinian entrance way through the porphyry columns,
through the doorways into the main body of the structure,
the same kind of marble pavements with a Maroon and green and white,
uh,
that we've seen in so many other buildings use tier marble revetment on the
wall.
You can get a sense of the groin vaults and the way in which they were probably
also decorated either with painting.
And stucco or maybe even mosaic,
the great coffered ceilings of the barrel vaults and look at the way in which
they've created a lateral,
a entrance arched entrance ways in each of these peers,
uh,
to create a greater flow of space just as you would see in a typical frigging
eum.
Uh,
and then again,
this opening up of this very impressive opening up of the walls with these
exceedingly large around headed windows that allow again light to stream into
the structure,
a real tour de force of Roman architecture.
In my opinion,
one of the greatest buildings ever built,
uh,
by Roman architects.
Believe it or not,
we have the portrait of Constantine us still preserved.
And I can show it to your,
at least bits and pieces of it,
a fairly significant number of bits and pieces,
including the head,
which I show you here,
which is now on view in the courtyard of the Conservatory Palace.
One of the,
uh,
one of the palaces on the Capitoline hill that belongs to the capital on
museums.
We see Constantine here and you can see how similar he is too,
that a transformed portrait that showed him as a neo Augustus with a neo Trey
Janick hairstyle beardless very clean shave and a very large eyes,
but very much in the mode of the earlier emperors,
Augustus and uh,
and Trajan rather than in the mode of the tetrarchy.
And yet a very abstract geometric image,
very much in keeping with tetrarch and constant Tinian art in that regard.
And truly colossal in scale.
We have a lot of the body parts that are also preserved in that same courtyard
from this same statue,
including the Shin of the leg from the knee down the knee itself,
and the way in which the knee is depicted tells us that the knee was bent and
the consequently,
this did indeed come from a seated statue of Constantine,
that statue that would have been in that left hand niche.
Uh,
we also see the famous hand from the statue as well as part of an arm.
And the arm is very impressive because if you look at it carefully,
you will see that the musculature is very clearly delineated.
Uh,
and you can even see the veins of the arms showing through the skin,
which shows you how adept artists still were,
uh,
during this time period.
These are right out in the courtyard of the Conservatory Palace.
Uh,
everybody,
this heart,
there's no tourists with a camera who goes by here without taking a photograph
in front of it,
including yours.
Truly,
I've done that.
I'm absolutely incapable.
I decide I'm totally incapable of going into this Piatsa and not taking a
picture either of whoever I'm with or them of me.
Uh,
and I have tons of these from,
you know,
years and years of posing in front of this is a pretty good Mediterranean Tan,
I must say.
And this not,
uh,
but,
you know,
posing with these,
with these hands and,
uh,
and feet and so on.
This is my son Alex,
posing on the foot.
Uh,
as you can see here.
so you know,
one,
one can't,
can't,
and you can,
you can only imagine.
I mean,
I,
I imitate the exact gesture up there and this image,
but you can only imagine the kinds of photographs that are taken in front of
that hand.
Uh,
and um,
uh,
you know,
as,
as Toro tourist after,
if you can find these actually on,
if you go on Google images,
you can find them quite readily out there.
Um,
so,
uh,
if you do go,
this isn't one of those other places and I hope if any,
have you traveled there and feel the,
uh,
the [inaudible] and inspiration,
so moves you to take a picture of yourself and send it to me.
I'd love to see it.
At any rate,
if you put all of those pieces together and they're actually two feet preserved,
two feet,
the Shin,
the knee part of the chest,
which we also have that arm that I showed you,
the hand and the infamous hand and the head of Constantine,
this is what you get a seat.
It statute 30 feet tall.
You've got a big building,
you need a big statue,
30 feet tall,
uh,
that sat in the main niche,
that niche to the left as you entered into the basilica of Maxentius Constantine
from the Roman forum.
Here's another picture of me,
although you can barely see me,
this was taken.
It's amazing that I was able to take this picture at one point with no one else
in it,
uh,
because the forum is usually so crowded.
But here I am standing with my back to us looking at the Basilica Nova and uh,
you can see how vast the great barrel vaults of the Basilica Nova are.
There are scholars who argue that Roman architecture declined in late antiquity
and not only architecture,
but painting and sculpture as well.
And one could make an argument.
I believe that Roman painting and sculpture did decline.
I'm not saying I necessarily agree that they did because art can sometimes
change,
uh,
for reasons that have to do with trying to articulate a different message than
you've tried to articulate before.
And a new style may be more appropriate for that.
Then the style that you've been using up to that point.
So I think it's a very complex matter when you think about whether it style,
whether,
whether aren't declines or not,
but I,
but I will go so far as to say without going into it in great detail,
although I'll say a little bit more about it momentarily when we look at the
arch of Constantine,
but without saying whether I believe that Roman art,
a sculpture or a painting declines.
I want to say categorically that I do not believe a that Roman architecture
declines.
And I think a building like this is a case in point,
this in my opinion is again one of the greatest buildings.
If you compare this to the coliseum,
if you compare this even to this sacred Pantheon,
uh,
if you compare this to some of the bath buildings that we've talked about,
as impressive as they are,
I think this takes its place.
The Basilica Nova takes its place among the most impressive works of
architecture that were left to us by the Romans.
And I think you can see what I mean just by looking at this image.
Because to still be able to create these kinds of soaring vaults out of
concrete,
to face them with brick,
to create a windows that are large enough to essentially dematerialize the wall
and the building still stands,
uh,
and still stands today.
The soaring vaults,
those soaring rib bolts or groin vaults that we see in the center of the space
to do that at this kind of scale is an incredible architectural feat.
I don't think there's any way that one can say that architecture declines during
this period when,
when looks at a building like this.
And also keep in mind how creative they've been,
that at this point in time they've decided,
uh,
to,
to create a bill,
a basilica in the form of a frigging Darian from atypical imperial bath.
That's a very creative thing to do.
And I think it couldn't have happened were it not that architect,
the creative juices were not continuing to flow,
uh,
for architects and artisans working on major projects like these in the time of
Constantine the great,
I want to turn from the Basilica Nova to the arch of Constantine,
which is the last ancient monument that I'm going to show you this semester.
Uh,
the arch of Constantine was constructed by Constantine to celebrate his victory
over Max Sanchez at the battle of the melody and bridge.
We big,
we think it was begun in 312,
a d and completed in 315.
And uh,
it is also possible some scholars have suggested that it's conceivable that Max
Sanchez may have begun this too,
in the same way that he began the Basilica Nova and that Constantine took it
over when he,
uh,
when he,
when he was victorious over Max inches at the battle of the Milby bridge.
We don't know which is the case,
whether he,
it was begun by Mac centers and finished by Constantine,
or whether Constantine began at himself.
I'm more likely to favor the latter that Constantine began at himself,
but we do not know.
And it's something that you should be aware of that particular controversy,
but it's certainly dates to this time period to roughly between 312 and 315 id.
One of the reasons that we believe,
I mean,
one of the reasons that the incontrovertible reason that we know,
uh,
that the building was completed by constantly busy inscription tells us it's a
constant Tinian building.
Uh,
but also there are phrases here that depict,
uh,
the battle of the mill vion bridge and other battles from that war.
Uh,
and show us,
of course,
Constantine victorious in those scenes.
It is a triple bade arch,
a very similar in that regard to the arch of Septum you severity and the Roman
forum.
And I don't think there's any question that the general format of it is based on
the arch of Septimius bears in the Roman forum.
It too,
like the arch of Septum Musa severity is covered with sculpture,
a veritable billboard advertising,
uh,
the achievements of Constantine in,
this important battle.
And overall,
uh,
but we see that of course,
instead of the,
uh,
the,
the panels,
the excerpts as I described them from the columns of Trajan or really us that we
see on the Septum,
the arch of September,
you subareas we see very different kind of sculptural decoration here.
It does cover the entire arch.
And it's interesting primarily because some of it is constant Tinian the parts
that are constant Tinian that were carved during the fourth century are the
spandrels with the victories.
Uh,
the spandrels with the river.
God's very much like the arch of Trajan it Ben event though the great the freeze
that in circles,
the all sides of the monument,
you can see that freeze here.
Uh,
the pedestals of the columns were also carved in the constant Tinian period.
and there are two round Dalles to round frames on either short side of the
constant Tinian monument that were also done during the constant Tinian period.
But what's particularly interesting is the fact that all the rest of the
sculpture a was cobbled together from earlier monuments,
and it won't surprise you to hear that they were the monuments of the emperor
Trajan,
the Emperor Hadrian and the emperor of Marcus Aurelius,
all the men whom Constantine considered the great emperors of the second
century,
a d the emperors of the Second Century d with whom he most wanted to connect
himself.
He read,
he inserts a sculpture from their monuments into this monument.
We don't know whether these were monuments that had fallen into disrepair and
we're lying in shambles,
you know,
around the city or whether he actually deliberately took apart earlier monuments
to extract from them.
The fragments that he wanted also very interesting is the fact that in all of
these scenes,
uh,
the scenes that are used from earlier monuments,
he replaces the heads of Trajan Hadrian and Marcus Aurelius with his own
portrait.
So he in a sense becomes them,
uh,
in this arch.
I,
let me show you quickly a diagram which will give you perhaps a better sense of
all of this.
The tray Janick.
The material from the tray Janick period includes statues of donations that come
from the forum of Trajan in Rome,
as well as from two patch panels for panels in fact too that are located on the
central bay on either side and two that are located on the sides on the attic.
In both cases.
Hadrian the round,
Dell's eight of them on the two long sides of the arch belong to some lost
hunting monument of Hadrian.
Uh,
the panels,
the vertical panels that you see in the attic come from an art to lost arch of
Marcus and real.
Yes.
And as I've already described,
the bases,
the spandrels,
uh,
and the freeze all belonged to the constant Tinian period.
I want to show you those very,
very quickly,
uh,
a panel on the left hand side from the forum of Trajan representing Trajan,
returning to Rome after his victory over the dations.
We think this was a pedestal or a base podium,
uh,
for the temple,
the Temple of Divine Trajan.
That was at the end of the forum and built by Hadrian.
We see a couple of the dations over here,
uh,
that come from the arch of the forum of Trajan,
the second story and the main part of the forum.
And Ben here,
these vertical panels that we believe come from a law starch and Marcus and
release.
Here we see that one,
a part of the constant Tinian freeze with Constantine seeded.
Now headless in the center here we see the round belts from a lost hunting
monument.
We believe of Hadrian.
Uh,
you can see a,
a deadline.
For example,
lying here.
Hadrian has returned from the hunt,
but the head of Hadrian recarved as ahead of Constantine and another scene over
here,
a sacrifice to Hercules,
uh,
as to who is floating in the upper most part of Bob.
But again,
the main thing for us is just that this comes from a Hadr Yannick monument is
reused here so that Constantine can associate himself with these great emperors
of the fourth century.
Another detail showing you the dations from the forum of Trajan as well as these
panels from this lost arch of Marcus really is probably originally dating to the
one seventies to one 80 had
a,
the what you see here are the spandrels with victories and a victory in the base
victories triumphant over a barbarian who kneels at her feet.
And if you look at these scenes,
if you look at these very carefully and you compare them to the little bit of
Roman sculpture that we've looked at in the course of the semester,
think of the our pockets for example.
When you think back to that and you look at these figures,
one could,
uh,
agree with the contention that this is not as good as it once was.
If you look at this figure of the Doughy,
uh,
season boy,
boy who's representing a season down here or this figure of the victory who was
not depicted a with the same finesse that we see the victory writing on the
shield on the column of Trajan,
I think a case can be made,
uh,
that this is not as as well rendered as it was once upon a time.
You can see that in the river God and you can definitely see it in this scene
here.
This is a scene from the constant Tinian freeze,
uh,
depicting the,
um,
depicting the siege of the city of Verona.
Very similar to that siege scene we saw on the column of Trajan with the
battering Ram.
And I think you can see as you look at these figures,
they are much more awkward in their emotions.
Look at these three over here.
Uh,
with the shields and the spheres,
they are exactly the same as if they were stamped out of a cookie cutter.
You don't see the artist taking the time to create distinction between them.
As you would see on the south freeze,
for example,
of the Arra pacas again,
there may be a,
there's a different visit,
different,
they have the different thoughts behind this of what they're trying to achieve.
And it may be that this different style better for what they've been trying to
achieve.
We've talked about this move toward,
uh,
toward abstraction and toward a geometry and so on.
But,
so I,
I'm,
it's not that I'm talking about this in a denigrating way.
I'm saying that it could be chosen for a different reason.
Tu Tu Tu,
Tu Tu.
It helps them,
it helps them present their case in a better way.
But I don't,
I think it's undeniable that it isn't as fine in quality as what we saw before.
And we see here,
this scene of Constantine on the roster and the Roman forum addressing the
people.
He's got the five column monument behind him.
But look at these statutes on either side seeded statutes.
We can identify them by their portraits of Hadrian and,
uh,
Marcus or release,
which I think demonstrates without any question head of Constantine is gone.
But he would have been represented with his neo Trey Jana care style in the
center flanked by Marcus Aurelius and by Hadrian I think that suggest without
question again that he is deliberately that he has taken these bits and pieces
of sculpture from other monuments in order to underscore his relationship to
these great leaders of the pagan past.
And I want a quote from Bernard Berenson,
the great art art historian in a book that he wrote called the arch of
Constantine or the decline of form in 1954 and I quote him as we look at another
detail from the constant Tinian freeze.
These stunted bodies are swathed in heavy blankets or covered with scanty
shifts,
both with the folds of the drapery as unfunctional as helplessly chiseled as
ever,
European art sank two in its darkest agent.
So that is,
that is a very damning,
a point of view.
Visa Vi this sculpture.
But again,
I think a case can be made,
but I'd like to say here today that I don't think the same.
They want to underscore that.
I don't think the same case can be made for architecture.
When you look at the buildings that we looked at today,
the basilica at the Palace of Constancia is Cloris,
uh,
finished by Constantine.
I think you will agree with me that this is a great building and a great
building.
Again,
rooted in the past looking to the future.
Uh,
when you look at something like the Tour de Scabby,
which we looked at last time,
a tomb that is based on the Pantheon in Rome,
but has the innovation of the porthole windows that we talked about,
architects still innovating,
still looking to the past,
but still an innovating,
uh,
the great baths of Diocletian on the left and of Constantine that we looked at
today.
Huge baths and the imperial tradition,
not very different from the bas of Trajan or the baths of Caracalla still is
great.
They could still build it this scale and they continue to innovate,
exploring new forms for the call.
Darian in each of these cases,
the Minerva Medica that we talked about today.
Yes.
And the tradition of round buildings in traditions of the explorations of
Hadrian at his villa or rebellious on the Palatine Hill.
Uh,
but about of a grand scale and with new innovations,
the placement of those windows,
those rounded windows at the base of the Dome rather than the Oculus,
the use of a decagon,
we'll plan innovative new things that haven't happened before.
So they are looking to the past.
They are building as well as they usually build a and they are continuing to add
new things.
When we look at,
in fact,
I'm reminded as I think about this,
a of the two round bells that were put up that were added to the Archie that
were put up in the,
that were made in the constant Tinian period for the arch of Constantine.
And I showed them to you here,
Luna in her,
in her,
in her chariot.
Uh,
the moon descending a cupid by her side and the personification of the ocean
Oceana's down below Luna descending and on the other side,
Apollo,
the Sun God ass ending from the ocean has chariot is going up towards the sky.
The puto.
The cupid leads the way with a torch just as every,
just as the moon descends and the sunrise is a civilizations and eras end and
other civilizations come to take their place.
And what happened at the very end of ancient Rome is that Constantine founds a
new capital.
He founds the city of Constantinople as the capital of the Roman Empire.
He does that in 324 a d.
And he dedicates it,
uh,
as the,
he dedicates this new city of Constantinople to the god of the Christians on the
11th of May in 330,
a d 330,
80.
So Constantinople becomes the new capital,
replaces Rome as the capital of the Roman Empire.
This may not have sounded so amazing at the start because we've already seen the
tech talks creating all kinds of new capitals.
The creation of a new capital wasn't that bizarre at this particular point in
time,
but he went on to decorate it with all kinds of buildings that look very much
like those in Rome.
And in retrospect,
we know that that move of the capital from Rome to Constantinople signaled the
death of Rome at that particular point in time.
And not to be resuscitated again until essentially the renaissance.
Uh,
if we look at some of the buildings that survived though from Constantinople,
we will see that they are based so very closely on those of Rome.
The hippodrome,
the sculpture at the base of the obelisk,
the aqueducts of Constantinople.
And of course,
especially the famous mosque of I is Sophia,
which you see on the left,
which would have been inconceivable without the architectural innovations of the
Pantheon.
So although we see that the capital from Rome to Constantinople,
uh,
that roams Rome's history at this point lies in the future when it's going to be
revived in the renaissance,
it's going to be looked at again in the baroque period,
uh,
and into the time of muscle.
And even today,
I,
one Roman architecture remains so influential,
but although,
but although again,
the argument can be made that sculpture and painting decline,
I think that architecture did not.
And the lessons that the Roman architects,
uh,
provided,
have lasted the test of time that they were passed on.
These,
these architectural wonders were passed on to the Middle Ages in the west to
Byzantium in the eastern part of the empire.
The Bay continue to be operative in the renaissance in the Baroque period,
in the time when Mussolini in the time of Richard Meyer,
indeed today.
Uh,
and I believe that they will continue to be significant for anyone designing
buildings.
They will provide an inspiration for at least the next 2,672 years.
Thank you very,
very much this semester for joining me on what has been in his special adventure
this semester.
And,
uh,
I,
I again,
want to thank you for that.
And,
um,
[inaudible].